there are nearly 2 million Palestinian
citizens of Israel
this is Haifa mixed between Palestinian
Israelis and Jewish Israelis the party
that represents the Palestinian Israelis
the joint Arab list won a record of 15
seats in Israel's Knesset the Parliament
that gives them more power than ever
before power they say will allow them to
represent more forcefully the interests
of Palestinian Israelis but what is on
the immediate agenda I'll sting a
current Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu the Prime Minister is indicted
in three different corruption cases
which presents the opportunity for the
opposition to pass a law if they can
form a government to ban indicted prime
ministers from sitting in office this is
one of the tools that we can do second
if someone will I will call us and we'll
appeal to us to use our power our 15
seats he would hear demands Civic
demands for the Arab community the joint
Arab list may support opposition leader
benny Gans and his blue and white party
to maximize their newfound power but
that comes with conditions dad's must
give the statement that the Palestinian
citizens in Israel are legitimate and to
have a statement against the racist
approach of Netanyahu that try to delete
itemize the heart of votes you cannot go
with guns when he is silent about those
major things supports doesn't mean the
joint Arab lists will join the
government they've already said that
they won't do that but what it does mean
is that they may support a government
led by blue and white leader been
against the palestinian-israeli vote hit
record levels nearly 98% according to
official figures Paris was one of the
people who worked on the get out the
vote campaign in Haifa at the beginning
I think it was a little bit hard and a
little bit difficult because a lot of
people in the society didn't you know
somehow trust the politician did
like politician that much but when we so
the things that happened you know in the
Jewish society and all the things that
they were saying about the our society
we we we wanted to you know to raise our
voice right now Palestinian Israelis
feel that there is an opportunity to
push their demands in the Knesset but
it's still anyone's guess who in Israel
be able to form a government and when
that might happen
Imran Khan al Jazeera -